his phone also
pasted and sent a message that said
call me at
956 whatever whatever
and i was like
huh that's weird and he goes ignore that
my phone just like pasted something from
earlier and i was like okay sex lines in
my pocket why is that their go to to be
like i have no idea
right obviously you [ __ ] know now i'm
pissed because i feel like you're lying
about it exactly so i [ __ ] went to
peoplefinder.com
i entered my my [ __ ] dollar 99 and i
[ __ ] ran the number
[Music]
hi everybody welcome back to another
episode of big mood
we are digital today because um we're
far as hell from each other i don't know
you know we're in three different states
yeah four
what do you say state of
depression um this is gonna be a ketchup
episode you know we haven't seen each
other in about what at this point maybe
nearly two months now a month a month or
so yeah it's gonna be a catch-up episode
lots of things are changing
uh lots of things are happening in our
lives and we want to tell you guys about
it because we don't have no one else to
talk to yeah yeah we need a validation
last time were you blonde last time
i was blonde last time and i went like a
milk tea brown now i wanna go darker i
like that
i don't know why you look blonder now
though really yeah yeah there it goes
yeah maybe just like got touched up so
your roots got touched up so it looks
possibly lighter i think that color
looks good i like that i like it i don't
like the really bright blonde on you
yeah i think i'm gonna stick with this
or go a little bit darker i think i
found my color
um let's start off let's you know what
let's start off with jess we never start
off with adjustments
what's up girl how are you doing girl
i miss you i started online dating again
um it's not been going well
oh god oh no as you've probably expected
she texted her group chat she was like
y'all
remind me to tell you guys about this
online dating snafu when we record so we
haven't even heard this yet i know i'm
so eager to hear this so um there was
two kind of uh back to back like bad
ones but i don't really want to get into
the second one but i will tell you guys
about the first one because i think it's
pretty funny um and you might think i'm
crazy but let me explain the whole thing
okay
something was oh what happened
no so okay so i met i matched with this
guy on bumble
and then we were talking and um it was
going pretty well i was actually really
excited to talk to him he was like hey
do you want to talk on the phone so we
did a phone call and i was like okay i
can talk to him on the phone and i
really like him on the phone too
nikki's yeah
he's just like i don't know what
happened
i need some of your light in my frame
like mine's so dark it was fine until i
took my sunglasses off and then it's
like you saw my socks
there's back to normal now how funny
that's so is it no it's still not crazy
yeah it's pretty bright
i just light up the room okay i'm sorry
go ahead
so um i'm trying to remember okay so
everything was going super well we were
supposed to meet on like a wednesday i'm
actually i've been off this whole week
by the way because i'm in between jobs i
got a new job i'm not going to talk
about it but i got a new job
so
thanks
um so i was in between jobs i was like
yeah i can meet you on like a wednesday
or whatever like i don't i don't have
anything else going on
um and then on a monday he was like do
you want to meet on tuesday and i was
like sure because it felt kind of like
there was a lot of momentum where he was
like
you know we were getting along really
well so i was like this is gonna be good
like i can already tell this is gonna be
good
and then so monday night we're texting
and i was like oh hey do you have any um
spotify
uh like give me a spotify playlist of
like edm or something like i want to see
what your taste is
and so he sent me he like copy and
pasted a spotify playlist into my text
messages
well somehow at the same time he copied
and pasted this spotify
playlist his phone also
pasted and sent a message that said
call me at 956 whatever whatever
and i was like
huh that's weird and he goes ignore that
my phone just like pasted something from
earlier and i was like okay sex line no
no
what was that
gina what are you doing
i'm curious
my attention is simple
she's just a squint to focus
i love this i didn't call it i didn't
call it i did do can we comment
no
we don't need to call it because i know
whose number it is oh okay okay
so i was like hmm
should i go to bed or should i
investigate my spidey sense because it's
kind of weird that it would just say
call me at whatever like that you would
have copied and pasted that in my head
i'm like you copied and pasted that from
bumble right like it's another it's just
another girl's number not a big deal
because honestly
we're all dating who's that we're all
dating thank you
so like i mean we're all like still like
i know that i just met you off the app
we haven't even met in person so i'm
like i get that you're probably still
talking to other people and like getting
numbers and like setting up dates or
whatever that's fine
but so i texted him back and i was like
so what was that number that you
accidentally pasted
and he goes i have no idea
and i was like
okay um well
you sure you don't know what it is
because like it seems like maybe it's a
copy copy and paste from bumble just
wondering and he was like no i have no
idea where that number came from it like
felt
like it fell out of the sky right
so what i did was in my life why is that
their go to to be like i have no idea
right obviously you [ __ ] know it was
on your [ __ ] like
exactly i'm like you know you [ __ ]
press copy
earlier like the clipboard on your phone
whatever doesn't last that [ __ ] long
like yeah it was from today so anyways i
was just like in my head i was like okay
it's obviously another girl's number i
don't care but like
now i'm pissed because i feel like
you're lying about it exactly so i
[ __ ] went to peoplefinder.com
i entered my my [ __ ] dollar 99 and i
[ __ ] ran the number and it was a
pretty girl
it was a pretty girl named pamela and
she lives in austin texas and i was like
and then so i was like ah bro you know
what guess what you just seem a little
bit busy i don't know like maybe we
should just call off a date i just feel
a little bit defensive already so he
calls me immediately he's calling me and
i was like
answer i was like we don't need to be
fighting about this like we're not
together yeah
and he was just like i i swear i don't
know what that number's from i have no
idea where that came from why don't you
call it you can call it right now i
don't even know who that is and i was
just like
well it's kind of weird because um it
just seems like it would be a girl's
number from bumble and it's like not a
big deal or whatever but he was just
like no i have no idea and so i was just
like well i ran it through i
googled i googled it and it's funny it's
a pretty girl named pamela who lives in
austin so you probably remember right
and he's like no i have no idea oh my
god he's sticking to it
he's just like he was like can we still
meet up can we still meet up and i was
just like i don't think so i'll think
about it and so i hung up and then like
10 minutes go by and i was like i can't
this is like major [ __ ] like red
flags not because he's obviously dating
at the same time
everybody is
it showed me so much about who he was
like he couldn't just be like this is
what i would have loved okay guys out
there yeah this is what i would have
loved to hear
i'm so sorry that i copy and pasted
another girl's number and you had to see
that it kind of broke the magic yes but
i would still love to meet you i think
like we could have a great connection
like will you still meet with me i'm
sorry that that happened like yeah yeah
oh my god just some honest communication
started
finally i was finally excited about a
guy that i met online and i didn't even
get to meet him because he was a [ __ ]
liar was the spotify playlist good job i
didn't even get to open it because i got
so [ __ ] preoccupied
and then i just deleted i just deleted
the whole [ __ ] thing yeah it that
means you didn't waste time so that's
good yeah exactly yeah but i mean it's
rough out here in these streets
damn what a disappointment it really
goes down that hard triple quadruple
downs that hard on like something might
happen
it's so minor too because i've just been
like yeah it would have just been like
yeah i get it like i'm still on the app
like we haven't even met yet we're not
dating yet it's fine but like why why
are you being so oh i got caught but i'm
going to lie about it yeah
imagine all the oh man
it wasn't so much more respectful or
respectable if you did just it's not
like we're all adults and we know that
people are dating yeah yeah it's like he
thinks i'm stupid so i'm just like oh
you don't know who i am i never know
i love it i'm so proud chess yeah i was
like i was like what would gina do
sometimes gina would have paid that 199.
yeah that's what you would have done
this is a type of behavior that a guy
ends up calling like all his exes or all
the
girls that he'd mess with
like they're all crazy like i don't know
why like i just have some crazy girls
like i don't know it's just like it's
because you're looking a liar exactly
look at your freaking actions look at
your actions that make
women go crazy it's like we
we all have the rational side where
we're like i don't need to look this up
i haven't [ __ ] what i would just want
to know
i'm so crazy i want it
intuition tingles yeah it goes off that
we're just like we can't ignore it we
just have to see we have to know was she
crazy or was she right and she called
you out on your [ __ ] you know what i
mean or maybe it seems crazy to you
because people are establishing their
boundaries and you can't stand that
exactly you know like all those times
that i found out you know that or the
last time when i found out that he
cheated was i crazy and insecure and
paranoid or was i right i was right you
all right
yeah every time i have that tingle too
it's always been right yes 100 of the
time
so i talk about like my ex and how i
went through his phone and i'm like i'd
never go through i never have the urge
to go through anyone's phone but for him
like i just felt it and then it was
right like there were
so many women
don't ever let me be confused if i have
to suspend reality
guys would just if i have to [ __ ]
yeah don't let me be confused if you're
asking me to [ __ ] believe
that your phone just copied and pasted a
number from like a month ago you have no
idea who that is
that your clipboard lasts that long i
have to suspend all of my reality that
you just this you'd no clue where could
that have come from right
but at the same time he could have been
he like even if he didn't want to tell
you it was another girl
he sucks at lying he could have been
like oh yes this new client that i'm
meeting we're meeting up for blah blah
blah i'm trying to negotiate i'm glad
that he sucks at lying though because i
got to find out
oh i'm trying to figure it out too
because that's hella weird like yeah
wouldn't you be like if that really did
happen
like i really i'm gonna try to figure
this out because like this is [ __ ]
weird and i'm tripping like yeah so
obviously like when you're on bumble
when you're on the dating apps like
people will be messaging and they're
like can i call you and then someone
will write okay go ahead and call me at
this number
it's bothering me i know it's so bright
okay since nicki nikki's causing so much
trouble with her let's talk about nikki
i'm sorry i just need all the attention
yeah i know you were on the news
you did something really cool what was
it oh yeah the news
well it was poker news yeah cool
it's like
it's like the coverage of all the like
poker world and they that's so cool you
know they do the play-by-plays of
everybody and and every in the big
tournaments and stuff but yeah i'm a
professional poker player now so like
that's why i'm like i got a hat and
sunglasses in my wsop
i'm just like you have merch dude you're
wearing all of your merch at the same
time girl
um no yeah you know i've been talking
about playing poker a lot on um our
podcast and
it started out as like something that i
was using as an escape and like got
really in like just obsessively into
studying it and like studying different
range charts and just game theory and
how like how professionals like
statistically are profitable in the long
run and if you stick to a certain you
know system and stuff and then there's
cash games and tournaments and i was
playing cash games only for a long time
and i thought tournaments were going to
be too hard because it's a lot of
variance like tournament you're probably
only making money 20 20 of the time is
like a good percentage to big money but
when you're making money you're making a
lot of money
if you're playing it right
um whereas cash games you're winning
like 60 of the time so it's like you're
willing winning smaller amounts but over
like a long period of time and so i felt
more comfortable with cash games but
because the wsop is in vegas and this is
like my first time in vegas during the
wsop i was like really excited it's all
anyone's talking about especially at the
cash games tables they're just like
are you playing do you know anyone
playing like everyone talks about it and
it's just a buzz so i was like you know
i really want to learn every aspect of
this game because i just love it so much
and so at the beginning of this year i
started studying tournament strategy and
uh it was really hard to get used to
because it's completely different than
cash games like just it's almost like a
different game um and then i i grinded
online for a while i was trying to get
the hang of it and then finally won my
first one online for two thousand
dollars it was a thirty dollar thirty
dollar buy-in and then i won two
thousand dollars in january and then i
used that to hire a coach
because i was like oh i didn't know yeah
i got a coach oh yeah yeah so like
all the best players that i know
even like especially the professional
players they all have a coach and so i
wanted a really good coach that
specialized in tournament strategy it
was really hard to find like i couldn't
get like a good referral um everyone
just told me to buy programs i had
already bought programs like gone
through
training programs and stuff and learned
strategy that way but i wanted like a
specific a coach to help me work on my
specific leaks like things that i am
personally doing wrong in the game that
could be fixed and so um i really wanted
a personal coach and uh finally i i
asked one of my professional poker
player friends andrew nimi shout out
he's also a youtuber vlogger he's uh he
vlogs poker he does poker vlogs there's
like a poker vlogging community too so
it's like a community within a community
and i kind of like joined up with all of
them and it's it's really cool it
reminds me of youtube way in the
beginning um everyone's like wanting to
help each other and stuff so he referred
me to my coach jesse sylvia and we
started working together and after the
first week of working together i won my
first live tournament i'd only played
one before busted the second one which
was right after our first coaching
session i got first place that was 100
buy-in and i won twenty-five hundred
dollars
and uh and it was with uh a field of
like 185 people
um so i was like wow that's really cool
but like i know variance is really crazy
so i'm just going to be using these like
low buy-ins as practices so that i can
feel comfortable playing like a side
event at the wsop
so the next week i was just doing it
weekly and i would grind online ones in
between but uh the next week i did that
same tournament the 100 buy-in and i got
fifth place which is still final table
which is where all the money is so
basically in tournaments all the money
is at the top like the top nine places
get the majority of the money and then
like
up to 20 places get like the minimum
cash um
at a tournament like that of that size
bigger tournament how much did you get
for fifth place for fifth place on that
one there was about 200 people and i got
about 800
oh okay yeah so not not a crazy amount
of money because it's not a big field
not a big buy-in um but these were all
like you know practices because i would
practice online and then i would try to
you know play live as a practice because
live is
just a lot more going on there's a lot
more visual stimulation going on you
have to like manually calculate how many
chips you have versus like what the
starting it's like it's a lot of math
going on um and then like there's
live reads like you're able to like read
people's energies which i like the best
see that's the reason why i can never
play poker because there's math
it's just basic math though gina
no see when i play d d and i roll my
dice i still count with my fingers oh my
god and my friends that i play with yeah
they're like oh it's so cute that you're
in character because your character is
like this kid i'm like it's not it's not
a character just own that gina don't
tell them don't tell them
adulting is hard whether you're studying
your butt off in college starting a new
job or just getting parts of your life
in order life can often feel like a
never-ending chore favor makes taking
care of your reproductive health easy
and painless the pill club is now favor
favor offers professionally prescribed
birth control subscriptions and sexual
wellness products delivered straight to
your door for free favor carries over
120 fda approved brands and ships to all
50 states most brands of birth control
are free with insurance or medicaid
otherwise prices start as low as seven
dollars per month without insurance
favor delivers birth control to your
door for free and discreet packaging
along with fun self-care gifts and
goodies what's more their licensed
medical team is just a text away to
provide you the care that you deserve
sign up for birth control in just five
minutes skip the office visit and
waiting in line at the pharmacy and get
treated right right now when you go to
hayfavor.com big mood favor is offering
a 10 donation to bedsider.org for every
big mood listener who becomes a patient
your donation will help low-income
individuals get access to birth control
through bedsider.org that's hayfavor.com
big mood to get your first birth control
care package and donate to help more
women in need of affordable birth
control remember that's hayfavor.com big
mood you must use the link to make a
donation yeah so then i was doing that
um my that was my first tournament was
the last week of march and then the
first one i won um live was the first
week of april so i've only been doing
them since then like
one to two times eventually i went to
two times a week and uh training with my
coach and like going over hand histories
and stuff and all i wanted to do was
play some side events of the wsop so i
did one two day tournament mgm grand
right before because i'd never played a
two day before and um it was 100 buy-in
and i ended up winning 12 grand in
second place that's the one i remember
you talking about yeah that was right
before you guys came over yeah and then
um i was like sweet so i'll use that as
bankroll for the buy-ins at wsop because
i'm only doing these like 500 buy-ins
which was still the most i had ever paid
um for that's a lot of money right
it feels like a lot because i was used
to 100 buy-ins being like the top and
that's like the lowest buy-in live um
but i was like yeah so this will just be
for fun um there's gonna be a lot of
people playing people come from all over
the world to play during this series and
of course they're doing the smallest
buy-ins because like
it's easier than than doing the the main
which is ten thousand dollars to buy in
so yes what's the price for that
millions whoa yeah like i think the top
prize is like eight million dollars or
something like that crazy this was not
the female event that you were joining
right the one there was were you still
going to do the future yeah the female
one is happening on june 29th that's the
one that's right before us going to
austin
so
that one's a four-day event and if i
happen to make it to the final then i
might miss my flight to austin but
you know that's it's worth it yeah i'm
willing to take that roll the dice there
if you're gonna make that much money
yeah so then this one was kind of
i considered like almost like a practice
wsop event like to get just to
experience like being there and like
it's really
exciting like there's just a bunch of
people from everywhere there to play
poker and like everyone that's all
everyone's talking about and um you know
there's the poker news there's people
doing interviews there's like all the
top poker celebrities that are doing
interviews and they're playing the
tournaments and you can just like watch
them playing in tournaments and i don't
know it's just really exciting
like it's it's like if you were into any
sport and you got to see like your
favorite athletes like playing and then
you can play with them like that's crazy
that's cool so any rich single
[ __ ] many
many
there's many handsome handsome
harder that's harder
[Music]
[Laughter]
it smells kind of like a gym locker room
in there yeah comic-con yeah exactly
it's just your type do you know she's
getting used to it
dude i feel like you and i are like the
same two sides of the same coin
yeah because of yours makes way more
money probably i don't know i think
you're making pretty good money
um that's awesome
like when you sent us the article i was
so stoked
yeah you look so cool
yeah yeah
i know when you said that that was like
a blog post or something i don't know it
was like poker news oh yeah
all the poker players
like watch poker news and like find out
like who was who ran deep in which
tournament and and all that stuff i
didn't really
know either like where people were
getting all the news from until they
started covering me and then i was like
oh [ __ ] this is like a big deal but yeah
to run deep in any tournament is like
really exciting but this one especially
because it's the wsop and because the
field is so large there's just such a
slim chance of you getting to the top
because of a variance like you're only
cashing 20 even in those smaller buy-ins
so this this buy-in there was 5717
people that entered and there were a lot
of professionals a lot of multiple
bracelet winners um
poker coaches you know people that have
been playing the game a long time and so
to for this to be like my first
series ever it was uh just like really
exciting to to do and i'm really
thankful for the
the prep beforehand that i was prepared
to go to final table i knew what that
felt like before because of the smaller
tournaments that i played and so it
didn't feel like so overwhelming like i
don't know what i'm doing here it just
felt like
a dream come true and i meant to be here
at this point i didn't expect to be here
this fast i thought maybe next year i'd
be ready to like make a deep run in the
series and this one was just going to be
to get my feet wet but just like
splashed the whole [ __ ] yeah i bet
all these like crypt of these uh are
sorry not crypto these poker [ __ ] mob
guys are [ __ ] leaning back reading
the news like who's this [ __ ] green
here's this limo green that came in and
busted the whole table and then you know
what the bracelet looks like what
bracelet it's gold
it's really pretty yeah do you want to
see it do the thing where you pull up
things on the computer like because you
know how to do this
do the streamer thing show us
wsop bracelets that's for a world series
of poker right yeah okay i'm not dumb
yeah no you know
well um
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah okay here here we go here
we go here we go it's like gold it's got
jewels on it is this it's a literal
bracelet uh it looks like a it looks
like a
do you did you get one no you're gonna
swing first first yeah okay oh that's
that's a different year so they do
different ones every year this is
hideous
yeah i'm not gonna lie
ugliest that's the ugliest [ __ ] i ever
seen just saw the diamonds and i'm like
oh and then i'm like wait yeah
20 22 is very nice
let's see 20 20
hold on
uh
they look really heavy it is
that one's better
2018
2018. okay
it looks like a a belt for the
ufc yeah yeah
oh it's like boxing 2022 okay here we go
oh this looks like it's closer to it
uh
maybe they haven't taken photos of it
yet they have photos everywhere yeah
here we go
you suck at this
[Music]
yeah
what am i looking at
it's a bracelet
it looks like see like a card it just
looks like a ring or something your mom
looks like a ring it's pretty solid it's
like a solid [ __ ] bracelet yeah it's
like solid gold
back to 2019.
multiple ones i'm you can you can win
multiple ones uh but like do people
actually wear no people don't wear them
but i would i would wear it in the
[ __ ] shower i would take that thing
off is it real gold
uh yeah i think so yeah it is i'm gonna
bite that [ __ ] and find out it looks
like the super bowl equivalent like
super bowl ring equipment yeah like a
high school graduation ring they do have
rings too the online tournaments have
rings it's called ring circuit um but
online tournaments are so much harder
because you can't make like live reads
and yeah and there's a lot more
more people
yeah so um that was really cool and then
it was what did you place for the second
one oh so i placed fourth for 116 000
dollars wow and it was a 600 buy-in so
it was a really good roi
yeah people were like are you gonna play
the main now and i really honestly
wasn't prepared to play the main i mean
it just seems really intimidating it's a
five-day tournament it's you're kind of
pushing your luck a little bit you're
the best poker players in the world but
for the experience
i thought it'd be really fun and like
kind of worth it and people afterwards
after i got that uh after i won fourth
in that tournament people were like are
you playing any more tournaments and can
i buy a piece of you so a lot of things
that like a lot of poker players they'll
sell a piece of their action and it's
very very normal in the community to
have people staking you so
like if the you're like a horse yeah
exactly
they give you part of your
yeah so exactly so if i have a ten
thousand dollar buy-in and i sell fifty
percent of myself then um
with whatever i win it gets distributed
to whoever however much percentage that
person bought so if you bought one
percent for a hundred bucks then
if i win a million dollars you get one
percent of a million dollars
yeah so it's not too bad yeah so people
do
so people do that cool yeah the number
one price how much was that for the one
i played yeah three hundred thirty five
thousand i think wow that's wild yeah i
was so close too at one point at the
final or right before the final table i
was second in chips and the third place
was like way behind
but then i did a dumb move stone
everybody
not be yourself
girl yeah yeah i'm happy i'm so proud of
you
thank you
so cool and it's just it's just cool
because i i love this community so much
and it feels like i belong now like it
just feels like i i feel like a sense of
belonging there and not just like i'm a
you know a fan and an outsider like a
wannabe
yeah exactly because i've i've won
enough tournaments now where i'm like
okay like i have a good
ratio going on yeah a lot of it is
variance i'm not gonna underestimate the
how much variance take uh plays a part
in this but there is a lot of like
skills and timing and patience involved
too so
and i had to i had to grind a lot to
like learn those things and i'm still
learning a lot um i played
yesterday for 12 hours and i busted the
first bullet uh and bought us a bullet
is like the first buy-in yeah no one
the knows one i made it all the way to
day two but um i have a very short stack
and like there's parts of me that i'm
like could i have played this
differently and had a better stack size
going into
day two and there's just a lot that i'm
still going over with my coach i'm still
working with my coach i'm not gonna play
like higher crazy stakes now like a lot
of people when they have like a big win
they go play like stakes that are way
above their level and they lose it all
and i just i'm not how do you eat and
like use a restroom and like yeah that
part is so hard
oh yeah i got a penalty i got penalized
for going to the bathroom yeah
whoa
you're supposed to not pee for 12 hours
no no they have breaks every two hours
but my bladder is on like an hour and a
half schedule
and especially because i'm trying to
stay hydrated it's very dry in nevada
and uh i drink a lot of water in general
and you have to be hydrated in order to
think properly so i'm drinking a lot of
water and my bladder just like an hour
and a half tops i'm like i'm bouncing at
my seat i'm like i cannot hold this any
longer and so
this guy was i was like very vocal about
how much i had to pee and how i was
gonna like sit out the next hand
and i was in the big blind which is the
one the only position where you have to
put money in the pot so you're forced to
be in the hand until somebody raises and
then you can fold your hand but um and
it has to come to you first before you
can fold and so i am like [ __ ] dying
like my bladder like i think i'm leaking
like i'm like i'm like i'm gonna end up
in a puddle of pee right here if i don't
leave like right now and this got
someone raised and this guy was just
thinking forever like forever and you
can call the floor if someone's thinking
too long but i felt like calling the
floor would take even longer and i was
just like trying to like be patient
enough to get through the hand and he
was taking so [ __ ] long i was like i
just gotta go and i folded my cards and
i and i left i ran to the [ __ ]
bathroom and when i came back they were
like uh the floor was at the table and
they're like
yeah you you're getting penalized
because uh you have to sit out two hands
now because um you were in the hand
already you saw your cards so it
basically gave information to the people
ahead of me that i wasn't gonna be in
the hand which could have been a threat
and a reason for them not to play the
hand so it like
it influenced the action of the game
and i understand but i'm like
holy [ __ ] i was gonna literally fill
this entire seat with urine oh no so
your penalty was just to sit out like
that yeah i had to sit out two hands but
it was like two hands i
in in positions i didn't really want to
sit out on but who knows those could
have been the hands that i busted a
tournament with and then i wouldn't have
made it that far so you never know like
every little bit counts like that every
little bit adds to the variance of
either making it or not making it and
you see what happens that is why you're
like mean you never drink water and your
bladder doesn't expect you to go pee
every hour i don't know it's that the
whole 12 hours just fine
okay
okay maybe you should play poker gina
yeah i will switch that's the only good
thing i have about it that i don't want
to because if i roll a dice i know how
many spaces to go yeah so i gotta count
we got some do some strategy switching
going on
what about you
oh um
so this is what comes out in july uh
i am still g4 i have my attack of the
show i just finished season one of my d
d show
and as of well now that we're recording
this two days ago we recorded the first
episode of
the uh new show that i'm on it's g4 we
teamed up with wwe wrestling wow i am a
coach
yeah it's a new show called arena and
i'm co-host now which i'm really excited
about we just filmed the first episode
today's saturday so we filmed on
thursday
in our new studio and everything so i'm
really excited about that awesome do you
have to know about wrestling do you have
to know a lot about it no okay sick no
but i'm getting like deeper into like
the wrestling world yeah and getting to
know everyone which is really fun i used
to watch wrestling when i was a kid i
used to watch when it was wwf yeah
that's how i know it as i hear wwe and
i'm like that sounds so weird yeah it's
really strange but um it's a federation
it's a federation
pandas wwf is now pandas yeah
yeah i think that's why they changed it
right because wwf like sued them or
something what does e stand for
entertaining entertainment wait world
wrestling
yeah you should google it before this
happens
world wrestling entertainment yeah i
don't know i think she's pretty open
about how she has to count yeah
still in character fair to talk man
you're just there to be hot let's be
real yeah i'm just there to be hot and
to talk about things
um
yeah so we just finished filming that uh
the schedule's slowing down a little bit
since i wrapped season one of my
dungeons and dragons show but um it's
been fun it's been really busy it's been
crazy
i really do wish i could travel more but
i'm learning so many new things and
stepping into
wrestling
yeah was something that i never thought
i would do when i was a kid you know but
i'm meeting so many cool wrestlers and
now my one of my bucket list items is
like
to like jump through a table or get hit
by a ladder or something wow you know
like i just want to see what it's like
they smash like a fake chair over here
they're actually real chairs i talk
crazy gina that's your kink we know yeah
you got another one
no i talked to the wrestlers i told him
i was like you know what i really want
to get hit by a chair now
and they're like dude it actually hurts
really bad it hurts more than getting
hit by a ladder and you also like
describe it yeah describe it
slowly i know
but i've learned so much like chairs
hurt more than letters tables are easy
like they're super easy and they don't
like fake it they're actually real
chairs they're not like pre
no
that's what i thought too perforated
yeah that's what i thought too and i was
like damn what do you guys do with these
thousands of chairs you guys destroy
every month [ __ ] like you guys are
putting like you guys are the people who
are keeping the business in business the
chair business and business
and they're like so what are you i was
like what do you guys do with the
destroyed stuff they're like usually
like we sign it we give to the kids and
stuff because i didn't realize this but
back then when i was watching wwf it was
very much like
rated r but now it's like super pg-13 pg
for kids so it's like a whole family
event now
um imagine aliens like looking at us and
like we're just slamming chairs and
tables they're like okay ladders hurt
less than chairs
but tables are easy like we just slam
tables all day long
like these are like yeah we're it out
we're not going to that planet why are
these people wild
um it's super fun because like i said
it's so pg-13 now that we went to a
wrestling show
with the house and stuff
and there's these kids sitting in front
of us um and we're so used to old
russell i was so used to old wrestling
and a few of us are like
[ __ ]
when the kids turn around like
and we're like
respectfully
[Laughter]
oh dang
but yeah it's been really crazy and you
know the funny thing is two days ago um
i was on my my facebook you know
facebook has like those facebook
memories
i posted 12 years ago um
holy crap i just got i got shown on g4
tv
um back when they were still like the
old legacy g4 tv channel and they were
at e3 and i was a booth babe back then i
used to work all the conventions as a
booth babe
and they just had me like wave the
camera and say hi welcome to e3 like
just like the most simplest thing
and i found it on my memories and i
tweeted it and i guess there's like a an
internet time machine or whatever that
people can use and they found the clip
from when i was like 20 years old crazy
oh my god that's crazy like it's come
full circle yeah
right you totally manifested it it's
really cool and it's funny because like
in that clip they cut me off at the end
yeah for a graphic
and it's so funny because now the
ongoing jokes sometimes they do that to
me on the show also when i'm introducing
a new bit they just cut me off the
graphic i'm like you [ __ ] never
change though
they're like we like you but that's
enough that's it
like so you can feel at home you know
nostalgic we got it you have boobs we
got the boobs
yeah yeah
we got the shot that clip back then i
didn't have boobs yet
oh my goodness it's even different
yeah
yeah not even notice
the girl before the boobs the girls
before the girls the girl before the
boobs who was she's behind the boobs
yeah
[ __ ] is so mysterious who is she
that's awesome um
and then wait this is july
episode then that means my birthday's
coming up too oh yeah 33. what are you
gonna do
i want to be at comic con
33 g4 yeah oh yeah you're so you're
doing it for work is it the san diego
one the big one uh the big one in san
diego yeah oh nice i've always wanted to
go um
so all these years like as a booth babe
i only went as like
um
i guess like as as a boothbay but then
like i never got to be in the the hall
it was just like all these activations
outside the main show so this is my
first time actually being
in the hall the main show and we have
like three panels that we're doing
so it's like a huge change yeah from
like what i used to do to now and but
it's still like in the same realm now
you're doing important stuff i know i'm
doing like weird important stuff now
like people actually want to come see me
talk which is like the dumbest thing
because like why
you know that's what i'm saying i don't
know right like you guys are dumb why
did you put me on camera i had to do a
meeting
um
uh the other day
it was like
i don't know like a bit
my president pulled me and like three
other hosts off the show because they
were holding like a summit
i'm attending summits now wow
that sounds special
it's so corporate
how are you handling it huh how are you
handling it does it feel weird
it's it was weird because like it was me
my three hosts and my president sitting
on stage answering questions to like a
hundred something people and they're all
from like huge huge companies some
fortune 500 companies because it's like
it's uh it's talking about um
uh like media traditional media and new
media and stuff and advertisement all
that stuff and like advertising with g4
and so it's like it was so corporate
and i was sitting there and i remember i
was sitting there right before everyone
came in i looked over at my host um
gerard i was like
i don't want to do this it's so
it's so formal i just want to sit and
talk about wieners they said i can't do
this
he's like i know gina just stick it out
for like 30 minutes okay i don't like it
you're like one two two
huge shout out to our sponsor today adam
and eve.com we have a great deal for you
guys if you don't know anything about
adamandeve.com well let's just say that
there are toys that are very pleasurable
to play with i just go to the website
and check it out and see what you like
on there and then go ahead and enter the
code mood for 50 off one item plus free
shipping in the us plus canada some
exclusions might apply but i want you to
go check out how they have 24-hour
customer service 24 7. okay not just 24
hour but seven days a week don't don't
forget that seven also they have 90 day
no hassle returns okay you don't like
that toy that you uh played with for a
little bit go ahead and return it hassle
free it says they got discreet packaging
so what you live with your parents don't
want them to know maybe they maybe they
put that it's a laptop in there you know
like studying materials
that's what you ordered off the site
they've been in business for over 50
years and 20 of their profit goes to
help the spread of hiv around the world
so go to adamandeve.com and use code
mood to get 50 off one item plus free
shipping that's adamandeve.com use code
mood m-o-o-d to get 50 off one item plus
free shipping wait you know what i just
realized uh you can say that this
episode comes out of july but no it's
actually uh coming out on the 28th
that's just so fyi which means
this episode comes out right before our
panel we're doing a panel in austin oh
yeah at rtx so if you're watching this
and you are in austin or you plan on
going to austin check us out at rtx we
have a panel on sunday july 3rd at 11 30
a.m
and that's the next time we're all going
to be together so i'm really looking
forward to that that's gonna be
luca's first time on an airplane
all together
and so if you're in austin and you play
poker i will be at the lodge playing
some crash games but my friends don't
know own
well they're
they're like poker vloggers and they all
own a card room together called the
lodge and i've been meaning to check it
out they have great tournaments and cash
games and do you know where that is i
don't but i heard that austin's kind of
small so like you could i think i think
i know where that is yeah i think i
drive drive by it it's kind of by where
i used to live before i switched
apartments okay well yeah you can you
come with me jess maybe you'll meet a
hot poker player guy
no i've already i got rid of the last
gambler that i dated it's too much for
me for my little gambling
it's too much for my last rounders
please
no
that's i'm scared of losing that much
money
are we gonna have our own hotel rooms
that we're sharing no we each have our
own but i forgot to mention uh for those
of you that care to join us at this
event you can click the link in the
description yeah cause you can purchase
tickets at a discounted rate it gives
you early bird rates
so the reason why i'm the one that knows
all this is because i'm the one
organizing it yeah yeah that's true
i don't know [ __ ] she just tells me
where to go she's she's our podcast i
booked everyone's flights like i i've
been in contact with
with rooster keith yeah i just want to
meet our fans so i can pickpocket them
and they hug them
and then we can go play cards
give me some money i know i'm trying to
i'm trying to fund mickey's uh gambling
here thank you i get a small cut of it
you know she's steak you're gonna
you're gonna yeah she's taking her yeah
you're gonna buy your racehorse
tip is anything new going on with you oh
and mom land over there in momland and
parent land i mean are your nipples
because lucas started doing this thing
now where he's like he's eating and then
he pulls away and i'm like
ow oh he's fine he started
yeah like he started to he doesn't have
like teeth yet but like the process has
begun and so he's like putting his mouth
in his thumb like he's he's sucking his
thumb now and isaac never sucked his
thumb so i think it's so freaking cute
really yeah isaac never sucked his thumb
and
i've never heard of that luca does and
so i'm like that's freaking cute i've
never seen that and then so
he just always has like his everything
like goes in his mouth now and yeah he's
always chewing and so he does that to my
nipples and so they hurt when he said
that i pictured those puppies when they
get a toy and they're like yeah
or they're pictures that are stretching
yeah yeah like the puppies that like are
sucking milk from their moms and they
like pull away that's what lucas is
doing about it
yeah do you remember joe dirt the movie
where like the dog got was on the porch
when the porch was frozen and his balls
got stuck to the porch yeah he's like
stretched out i picture luca's just like
stretching out yeah it's truly like he's
doing this to my nipples yeah like
yeah i actually looked at them too and
i'm like oh my god they're purple like
they're actually so like bruised like
they're actually bruised
but yeah so that's kind of happening but
this summer though is really exciting
because we are doing a lot of traveling
we're actually
so like the austin trip is kicking off
or actually vegas
technically kind of kicked off our
travel for the summer but we're going to
austin from austin we're driving up to
dallas to go spend time with casey's
family and then isaac is flying into
dallas to meet us there because he
wanted to skip austin and spend 4th of
july with his dad
and then um from dallas then we're going
to spend time there and then fly to
orlando and we're going to spend a
weekend with my cousin who lives there
and then a whole like five six days
um we're gonna be staying at one of the
universal hotels and then we're gonna go
to
like animal kingdom ecot and hollywood
studios at
disney world and then we're gonna go to
the two parks at universal and it's just
just gonna be the four of us so it's
gonna be the first time like
i don't know it's like we're really
ambitious we're doing a lot with the
baby
five month old he'll be five months by
then yeah and and again like the first
time flying and we're not like we're
gonna be flying to
you know multiple places
and then coming back home staying here
for a month
and then in august we're going to um
we're flying into boston
and spending time there and then we're
going to drive to rhode island because
that's where casey's brother and his
fiance are getting married so we're
going for that trip for their wedding
and then spend time in rhode island and
then we're gonna drive
through um like albany and aurora and
then end up in buffalo and we're gonna
go see the niagara falls and i'm like oh
it's so freaking fun it's like another
thing on my bucket list
but yeah and then this we're all doing
with the chan clan minus obviously the
brother and the fiance because they're
going to go off to their honeymoon but
yeah i don't know it's just really
exciting that's a lot
yeah i'm exhausted just hearing that i
know
i'm so pumped because like you know us
like casey and i love traveling yeah and
like we love like
showing the world to isaac and now we
get to do that with luca and like he
doesn't know what's going on though i
know right now
he is absorbing it all though and it
definitely is like and then not just
that but we're all creating memories
together like with him he's gonna be a
patriots fan and they're like how you
picked that up like he's jumping to
boston for a day
but yeah like i don't know just getting
to
explore the world and have adventures
and now like with luca joining us and
isaac will be with us and i don't know
how are you going to keep yourself from
losing your absolute [ __ ] when luca
is like going crazy while you're
traveling it will happen but he's i mean
he loses the [ __ ] here sometimes too so
i'm like it's fine you're like i guess
you might as well be in boston or new
york you might as well go out and
explore the world yeah because like i
don't know like i see i follow a few
people on instagram that are like moms
that travel a lot with their kids
and or like with the baby or something
they're like yeah like having a baby
isn't gonna stop me from like seeing the
world and plus like it's enriching for
the baby too to see different
environments
and i don't know i really i fully agree
with that like i i don't want
like having
kids to be a hindrance on exploring and
like continuing to travel and like
and like yeah just
explore even more cultures like
eventually we like we were talking
because casey's parents are super like
travelers too like they're every month
they're going to a different country
like they're constantly traveling oh
dream
yeah like they're loving their retire
like they're like semi-retired right now
so they're constantly traveling and
like you know now we're talking about
like oh we should like do a
a cruise in europe or something and like
just take the whole family and like have
everyone
just
i don't know like we
like they get it you know like they do
like the blood
like yeah like
i married into the perfect family
that wanderlust like just wanting to
explore and just see different places
and
see all the things and eat all the
things and yeah just everything i love
it
so lucky i've been dying to travel man
it's been so long yeah you're stuck to
your little nine to five
g4
i got the travel bug for like a couple
years and then i feel like yeah i think
i've seen enough cities
i've seen enough beaches in cities i
like i like vacation it's like fun to go
to the beach but
i think i like i don't know like it left
me and i'm like
wanting to i was like that's what a
little bit yeah because we did we took
we did this ridiculously long trip in
2018 i think it was
like we were gone for an entire month
like casey and i we went to so many
different countries we did so i remember
that when he was like oh and like all
those places yeah to morocco croatia
like uh [ __ ]
i don't know english everywhere you went
everywhere well iceland was twenty-nine
yeah like we literally went everywhere
that month it was so much to the point
where i was like i'm tired yeah i don't
want to go anywhere and then the
pandemic kids and then it's like two
years three years of doing nothing
almost where i'm like okay now i'm back
like yeah after about five days i
started missing my cats
and my bed
yeah but
it's really cool i'm excited for you to
go see places that you haven't seen yet
like niagara falls that's really cool
i haven't even seen the grand canyon
like and it's right it's really close to
me now but
like i haven't even seen a lot of places
in america
yeah
yeah same i think i flew over it when i
left uh vegas yeah i flew over the grand
canyon for some reason to get back to
texas because i was flying over and i
was like oh is that it
yeah okay but also
like you know 30 000 feet so probably
like smaller
yeah did you then it does like if you
were in a helicopter did you guys do the
helicopter ride in grand canyon or was
that the city one tiff
didn't you guys do a helicopter sorry
didn't you do a helicopter right here
yes yes yes yes grand canyon or did you
yeah we did we did grand canyon how was
that was the first time i saw the grand
canyon i've never seen it either and
then that was also the first time doing
a helicopter ride and yeah you see that
that was freaking cool like we they
actually like
have us in the canyon so like we were
like we were in the canyon they also
have
they have other tours where they land
the helicopter in like a certain spot
and you can actually get out of the
helicopter and like be in the grand
canyon but we didn't do that one
um but it was still really sick like
just to see it and i was really
grateful that that was my first grand
canyon experience and not
the like two three hour bus ride or
whatever however long it takes to like
go and then
and you're gonna write a donkey or
something all hot and lots of people and
i don't know
yeah
no the helicopter was really cool like i
think i'm good like check yeah i don't
have to see
like yeah
i was never
really excited about like um landmarks
because i remember went to paris first i
went to paris i was like
we drove past the eiffel tower i was
like alright cool
you know i'm still the opposite i cry i
literally
well yeah the first time i saw the
eiffel tower i literally cried
like i it's just so
you know what happens to me i
when i was little
and like living at in like my trailer
park home and like seeing on tv like all
this
world
because i i had i was in a mobile home
it was like tiny and me i'm living in my
trailer in my trailer
no i cry looking at
i cry looking at the monuments because i
think about that little girl who just
wanted to see the world and like i
connect with her immediately when i'm
seeing these like monuments or like
these places around the world that i
thought i would never get to physically
go and see for myself with my own
eyeballs like i always saw it through
like through tv or a movie or whatever
and i'm like whoa like i wonder what
it's like to be there and like to
actually be there i connect with that
little girl
and so that's why i cried i think that
was always in you then you know
i really think that like there's
something in all of us that's like it
take it wants you to go that direction
you know and there's like little signs
of it from when you're on like gina's
[ __ ] 12 years ago story like there's
always like these signs and hints of
like what you really want to do where
you really want to go and like that's
really cool that you
feel that way about fulfilling like your
child's your child's wants and needs i'm
like eugena like ice i've seen landmarks
and i'm like huh because i always saw a
picture of it and unless it's
interactive like i really love beaches
because i [ __ ] love the water
like if i like i used to
dream about like i still dream about
flying to tropical beaches and like i'm
actually like flying as a person and
like i fly to a tropical beach and then
i go in the water and those those things
are really cool but um yeah the landmark
thing same i went to buckingham palace
and i was like all stoked and then i was
like oh
yeah okay
yeah i wish it was more like a tiff yeah
i wish it would be like that
mm-hmm why i saw a buckingham palace and
i didn't cry okay
okay maybe that's normal
have more strength to them i guess i
wonder if you could feel the history too
like if you went
to rome or italy like the leaning tower
of pisa or like if you went to like the
what's it called amphitheater in rome
like
yeah i've been to those too and like i
literally hold back tears too oh yeah
oh yo
you would love this tiff did you hear
about how disney is doing this thing
yeah
it sounds
dope
and like honestly it's really good value
if you have that kind of money yes have
that kind of money oh yeah
wait elaborate for those okay i don't
know so disney is doing this is not
sponsored by the way but disney's doing
this thing where it's a 20 you buy this
24 hour 24 day trip it's a it's 24 days
long it's a hundred fifteen thousand
dollars a 24 day long disney trip in a
private jet and they take you to each
private chef and you get a private chef
and a private jet doctor and they and a
doctor on board too
and they yeah and they take you to each
disney park around the world and while
you're there you have the option of
going and exploring different cities
like paris and seeing the eiffel tower
or like seeing the the
visit the pyramids of giza yeah there's
not a disneyland there but they're gonna
go out of their way to like take you to
monuments like like yeah the pyramids
against the taj mahal yeah yeah like
there's no there's a lot of places that
you wouldn't ever like maybe get to go
to it's part of the trip too yeah and
you're traveling the entire time on
private jet with the private chef like
for
fifteen thousand dollars it's like yeah
that's a ton of money but like that
value for a month long and seeing all of
those places like yeah how many
countries it is but you're traveling
around the entire world and going to
disneyland like even like a [ __ ]
one-day trip with a family to disneyland
is like a thousand dollars could i do
all of that and just not do this
yeah
sam you and me i don't really care for
disneyland
the chef yeah the doctor
on the rise yeah
i need to win like five more poker
tournaments and then all of us can come
back bye nicky i'll go with you okay
right now cause like i actually i just
have shanghai to check off and then i'll
see i have seen all the disney castles
around the world wow because every
disneyland has a second park
or like in orlando they have like three
other parts
um so i yeah we've casey and i and isaac
we've been to paris hong kong
orlando here in l.a
uh wait i said hong kong um
yeah we we're missing shanghai so i'm
like [ __ ] i really want to go to
shanghai like check out a long flight
i know
but yeah just drop us off like you two
go inside me and jess will just be at
the door we'll leave we'll turn back
around we're gonna explore the city and
stuff just like smoking on a corner
outside
paris i'm definitely not going to hang
out with a bunch of children let me tell
you that
you're going to be experienced
it's probably just all the disney adults
that have grown up i don't understand it
that's only the small part of the trip
like you're in the disneyland parks for
like
how many parks are there like five or
something so then then each one has
multiple okay so maybe like a total of
like eight to ten days out of the 24 day
trip you're in the parks yeah but then
like the rest of the time you're seeing
other landmarks and cities and
eating private chef meals and
i would do one day at one disneyland
yeah
the japanese one good compromise
the japan one that seems cool i heard
that one's tiny right oh yeah i forgot
japan doesn't mean oh is it small
i know you're smaller yeah smaller but
you know also what i learned about the
japan one is that one's the only
disneyland in the world that's like
privately owned like they're like
licensed
really so if you have like a disney pass
or whatever like you can't use it you
can use it on all of them except in
tokyo um something like that wow i
wonder how they pull that off they like
to have control over their [ __ ] i guess
it's like how the packers are the only
publicly owned football team oh really
yeah i'm an owner
yeah you are well
i have one share i knew that was coming
i wanna have one chair so i could say
that yeah
yeah
it's like oh you play it's not special
when 100 million other people own a [ __ ]
special
i'll put it on my instagram profile yeah
i have it framed somewhere that's cute
yeah i'm going to hear it
yeah
still hanging [ __ ] up around here
so i'm excited to see you guys in austin
though i know i've never been to austin
that's it i haven't been i've never been
to texas in general whoa yeah
my texas virgin oh nice oh she gives you
the biggest guns to shoot
i feel like the worst person i have that
dude let's not have the gun conversation
that's very that's a big thing
there's like there's like a our
governor's like the his uh competitor or
whatever is like inching closer and
closer to him because like there's a lot
of people getting really upset about the
gun issue here so listen i don't shoot
guns
um but i
there was this purse in vegas that's
covered in sparkles and it's shaped like
a gun and it's like
a really close okay it's really cool
looking at first
i told the lady at the like when i was
there to register for the wsop i was
like if i win i'm coming back for this
purse
and did you go get it i haven't gotten
it no
how much was it it's 500 bucks
that's not bad i know but it's like it
doesn't fit anything and it's just
your phone does not fit you could hold
like 10 points in it
oh my god jeez that's five okay for 500
now you could oh my gosh okay it's like
the size of your phone and both the
handle but your phone doesn't actually
it's fit it's like not the right yeah
yeah that's for 500 yeah you got to at
least for your facilities credit cards
yeah i agree that's what we're going to
do
it's going to be your city what are you
going to do yeah
apparently nikki is going to leave us
and go play poker the whole time so no
one goes to sleep i'm gonna play all
night like you guys will be in bed
you'll be drunk you'll be in bed i'll be
like okay and i'll sneak out like
backwards
this has been so weird since i moved to
vegas i literally played from 8 p.m all
the way to 5 in the morning and i drove
home when the sun was rising i was like
i never
yeah that's why i'm so tired because i
played till 1 30 in the morning last
night and i started at 11 a.m and
tournaments start way earlier than cash
games like cash games i usually start at
like six or eight like somewhere between
six or eight like around dinner time and
then i play until like three in the
morning
um that's really unhealthy to be
sleeping
to be shifting
your sleep i'm telling you it's going to
catch up to you why can't you play
during the day they don't have
tournaments during the day no
tournaments i'm playing during the day
just goes all day like from 11 to 1 30
at night wow cash games i you play at
night because that's when the money is
like all the drunk ass
people visiting vegas that think they
know how to play poker come in so that's
when that's when you can attack yes
these are the best the good games are at
night the locals attack hour but i only
play like three days a week like not
every yeah yeah that's good and then i'm
working online i'm so shocked that this
is nikki now like right now
i
i would never would have guessed
right like even five years ago if you
were like yeah you're gonna like get so
into poker that you're gonna deeper to
the wsop i would be like what no me okay
that sounds cool but
yeah you're doing so cool
i know
all right let's wrap up this episode um
it was nice catching up with you guys
hope you guys like this episode catching
up with our lives
uh and make sure you guys check out
first wait
wait
gina streamer thing you don't like you
don't like
you don't like eyelashes on a car but
you have them on your [ __ ] bed
should die
and i you're just sleeping because your
eyes are closed you know like
and i just say live things and thanks
for watching our live i'm sorry thanks
for watching this episode we love you
guys see you next week okay
we actually see you this weekend if you
purchase tickets in the description yeah
yeah
meet us
tell us how much you love us
all right
[Music]
you